hey everybody time once again for
flickers of fear and
yet again we're continuing with
giallo july now this is a little bit of
an unusual one what ended up happening
with this
was that when i first announced that i
was going to be reviewing jello movies
all throughout the month of july on this
flickers of fear series a listener out
there recommended a film several times
that i had actually never heard of
called discopath because it has a title
like that and the poster is wicked cool
i was like okay well obviously i can't
resist checking out something like that
and they were like hey um review this
for your giallo month because it kind of
fits in uh so it's available for free on
2b so i kind of toddled over there and
gave it a watch
now i will say that discopath isn't
exactly a giallo film
though it is pretty heavily influenced
by kind of tropes of the genre it's
actually kind of more of a straight up
slasher movie with sort of like a
throwback 70s vibe
so this movie was actually written and
directed by a guy named renault gautier
hopefully hopefully i'm kind of
pronouncing that right uh this was
actually his film debut i think he's
made a couple of other films
subsequently this is a french canadian
production and it premiered first at the
fantasia film festival in montreal back
in 2013
and ended up opening in the united
states limited run obviously at the
american cinematique in los angeles and
it was actually they put it on a triple
bill with the 1982 like slasher movie
pieces and the 1980 classic canadian
slasher prom night uh so that would have
been a really good triple bill to see
back in 2013. so
we start out we have like this really
really groovy
title sequence that utilizes the
excellent uh 1976 song which is called
flight 76 by walter murphy or the walter
murphy band which is essentially i'm
sure you probably heard it but it's like
a disco-five version of like flight of
the bumblebee i think my dad had it like
on vinyl like way back in the day but
yeah so the opening credits are like set
to that song and it's really cool
so after that we're introduced to our
titular discopath who's actually this
sort of awkward
not all that talkative young man by the
name of dwayne lewis
now when we first meet him he's working
as looks like a short order cook or
something like that like in a diner in
new york city but he's clearly not
really cut out for this [ __ ] he's
getting like really overwhelmed and then
like a group of guys sort of like stroll
into this diner and they have like one
of those big 1970s boom boxes and it's
blasting some of that newfangled disco
music that we all love so much that the
kids love so much today and hearing that
it sort of sends him into this kind of
like trance and he spaces out and it
ends up culminating with him starting
like a little bit of a fire on the grill
and so the owner of the joint is just
like you know you can't do this just get
the [ __ ] out of here you're fine so he
just like takes off so uh as he's sort
of glumly contemplating his recent
joblessness in a nearby skate park not
so much skateboards i guess there's kids
on skateboards but it's mostly people
roller skating but it's clearly like a
skatepark
so while he's there dwayne actually gets
approached by this hot brunette on
roller skates and her name is valerie
now she like i think she either
remembers him from
from a street they used to live on or
she's seen him at the diner or something
like that but anyway she kind of
recognizes him and she's like oh i
always thought you were cute so she like
you know comes on real strong and he's
just like very awkward you know he's
very awkward so he's just kind of like
oh okay uh yeah so there's that kind of
thing uh so even though he's not really
talking all that much and even though
he's being kind of like weird because
he's not really he doesn't really have a
lot of social graces and even though her
friends are just kind of like him okay
whatever you know what i mean and
they're just like we're getting out of
here you just do whatever the [ __ ]
valerie uh but she actually ends up
digging him enough to invite him back to
her apartment for a beer and probably
other things as well uh you know
considering how like i said very forward
she is
and shortly afterwards she actually
persuades him to
accompany her to a discotheque called
seventh heaven
uh that evening which is apparently
she's a place a place she's a regular at
now she even loans him some kind of like
saturday night fever looking threads you
know i mean she said oh it was my dad's
and it's just kind of like you know it
kind of looks like that john travolta
kind of like outfit
and so dwayne is pretty weakly like
trying to protest he's like i'm trying
to get away from the music i'm not
really into music i don't know anything
about it but she's like kind of super
pushy um you know she's trying to get
him to go out and have a good time
because she likes him and her pushiness
is actually an attribute that will uh
directly lead to her horrible demise
spoiler alert now interestingly the
murder itself because she does get
murdered um this is a slasher movie but
it isn't shown right away so it's like
interesting how this movie is structured
what happens is instead we like skip
from dwayne and valerie like going into
the club
and then we like just jump ahead to the
following morning and we see dwayne
who's obviously very panicked and he's
kind of scrambling to like get rid of
his blood-soaked clothing and he's kind
of like reaching in the pockets i don't
think the clothes are his actually now
that i'm thinking about it but he like
reaches into the pocket and there's like
a severed hand in there and he's almost
just kind of like oh my god what the
[ __ ] did i do last night it's almost
kind of like that kind of thing
thankfully it's like i've you know i've
had nights where i drank a lot and
didn't really remember what happened but
i'm very happy to report that i've never
pulled anyone's severed hand out of one
of my pockets the next day being like oh
my god what the [ __ ] did i do but that's
essentially what what he does then he's
he uses the money and the identification
from a wallet that he stole from the
club's owner because i think the jacket
that he's wearing he actually got it
from the club owner somehow um they
don't actually show that but you know
it's just one of those things where it's
like oh it's the morning after you kind
of have to like put the pieces together
what happened the night before so
because he has the money and he has the
id and there's also a passport in there
which is uh you know convenient then he
kind of books it to the airport and he
gets a one-way ticket to montreal
leaving new york city behind for good
now valerie's actual death which is
shown later but like as a flashback
it's probably this scene in particular
probably like a couple other ones too
but i think it's this scene in
particular that kind of gets this one
associated with giallo movies because
her death is actually i think one of the
best sequences in the movie um and it's
very very much like something that dario
argento would have shot like back in the
you know early to mid 70s it's kind of
like like valerie obviously has her hand
cut off like you know he's he hears
disco like the groovy beat or whatever
and then he starts flipping out and he
starts chasing her and then he basically
like cuts at her hand until it's almost
chopped off and then she's like running
away
and then she actually ends up trying to
hide from him but the place where it is
is like underneath the dance floor it's
almost kind of like this little i don't
know like this little cabinet thing that
she crawls into and it's like underneath
the dance floor because the dance floor
and the disco is clear and then there's
like all these colored lights like
underneath it so it's like when all the
lights are on like it looks like oh all
these lights colored lights like coming
up through the clear dance floor it's
like really cool looking so she's
actually like underneath the dance floor
while all these colorful lights are
flashing and all the disco beats are
pulsing in the background and just all
these oblivious dancers are just like
boogieing away like inches above her
dead body like while she's kind of like
you know scraping at the floor like
trying to get people to pay attention
but it's too loud in there so that's
like really really a great sequence very
very giallo-esque like with the lighting
and the color and everything like that
so after a brief scene where the nypd
kind of fruitlessly attempt to solve the
crime the movie kind of like takes off
in a different direction which i
actually wasn't expecting so i thought
that was like kind of interesting it
actually moves from english to french
because like i said this is french
canadian it was shot in montreal quebec
and uh not only does it switch from
english to for almost all french now but
it jumps ahead to 1980 because like i
said at the beginning it set it like
1976. so dwayne is now using the name
martin lopez which was the name of the
club owner whose id he stole so he um
has been working as an audio visual
technician at a private catholic girl
school in montreal quebec where he ran
off to after he killed valerie
and he's been wearing hearing aids in
both ears and all the staff at the
school believe that he's a deaf mute but
the only reason that he wears them is so
that he can block out like any sound you
know so he doesn't take the chance of
like hearing disco music again and you
know making him flip out and go on a
murderous rampage
not surprisingly uh the homicide-free
lull that dwayne has experienced for the
past four years while he's been working
at this uh school
is not destined to last and it isn't too
long before
students teachers uh at the school as
well as a couple of dancers on a local
tv show which is called discomania end
up falling into the crosshairs of his
deadly mirror ball of murder if you want
to call it that so this was a very odd
but also like kind of an enjoyable
little movie it's it's very clearly low
budget i don't know how much the budget
was like the wikipedia page didn't say
but it was obviously made with a lot of
love for the giallo and slasher movies
of the 1970s and 1980s it has like a
really cool like retro look to it
um the premise is of course naturally
ridiculous
but interestingly the film is played
almost completely straight like it's not
so i don't even know if i would call it
like overtly a horror comedy even though
like
the premise of a serial killer who
goes into a trance every time he hears
disco and starts killing people is again
essentially ludicrous
but
it's mostly played straight and i think
to a large degree that works the only
thing that's a little bit weird and i
think this makes like the tone a little
bit uneven is that some of the cop
characters like the characters playing
cops are just like slightly over the top
so it almost seems like the guys that
are like the cop characters
almost seem like they think they're in a
comedy but not like overtly you know
what i mean like but they're more aware
of like being in a comedy but everywhere
everybody else like including the guy
that plays dwayne and all that kind of
stuff are acting like really really
serious so the tone is a little bit
weird but like i said i think it's
listed as a horror comedy and i don't
know if i would go that far yes the
premise is ludicrous but it's mostly
played as a straight
uh slasher and i mean there's kind of
like little funny bits in there but it's
not like overtly a comedy if that makes
any sense like it's kind of hard for me
to explain also i will note that some of
the obviously canadian actors
are trying a little too hard to sound
like new yorkers like at the beginning
like at the first part of the movie
that's set in new york city especially
like the girl that plays valerie i mean
it's just very very i know some like
some new yorkers have very very thick
accents but i think they were trying way
too hard and you could tell that they
were canadians and i know that they
didn't really want to sound like
canadians because canadians sound like
canadians but it's just seemed like they
were trying a little bit too hard for
like that for that over the top like new
york accent when they probably should
have just like chilled out about it but
to be honest that just kind of like
added to the movie's charm i guess
because i don't know there's something
about like some canadian particularly
canadian horror movies where
they're always trying to
make it seem like the united states even
though it's clearly canada uh and even
though all the actors are clearly
canadian but i think like the funniest
the funniest thing about that to me was
that there's like a very brief kind of
like i guess it was like a joke like a
scene where dwayne like after he kills
valerie and he goes to the airport like
to fly to montreal
there's a scene where he's like going to
the gate or whatever and this marching
band this small marching band that's
carrying this massive like american flag
behind them like just comes through
just comes through like the airport
playing yankee doodle dandy and i was
just kind of like and i think i mean i'm
pretty sure that was done on purpose
because like i said there is kind of a
tradition of canadian horror films in
particular kind of like putting little
american flags on you know on police
officers desks and stuff like that is
like this is for real america it's not
canada and so i just thought they were
kind of making like a little nod to that
which this very obvious like marching
band why would there be a marching band
like in a [ __ ] airport playing yankee
doodle deity of all things of course
there never would be but i just think
that was like kind of funny but so this
the humor is kind of like that it's kind
of just like the little subtle kind of
touches which i actually really
appreciated now interest another thing
that's interesting about this is that
the kills actually start out kind of
slow like i said he kills valerie first
but they don't even show that until
later and even though the sequence where
she gets killed is really stylish it's
not all that gruesome i mean she does
get her hand like kind of torn off and
that's kind of gross but it's not like
super over the top
but the movie gets a lot more violent
and a lot more like disgusting like as
time goes on which actually kind of
surprised me but like in a good way uh
the special effects work for considering
what the budget probably was is actually
quite good a couple victims get beheaded
and you know the guy like carries the
heads around and does all kind of crazy
[ __ ] with them like putting them on
turntables and stuff um the bodies get
like pierced with
vinyl records like 45s um and actually
what is a really good scene like them
sticking in there it actually looks
really realistic um there's a great
scene toward the end where there's like
this big uh you know he he's kind of
like in a car and he's trying to like
hit all the people like in the funeral
like are some of the victims that he
killed and he hits one car and like one
of the bodies like comes flying out of
the coffin and the head had been taken
off and so obviously it was sewn back on
so it's kind of like hanging off like
that and that was like actually really
really good so you know and the car
crash actually looked looked realistic
there's a point where someone falls off
a building and makes like a really nasty
mess on the street below so this does it
doesn't start out with like a lot of
violence or gore or something like that
but it kind of like more than makes up
for it toward the end like it gets
really really gory like toward the end
which i really liked so
you know while disco path it's not
strictly a giallo because it's not
really a murder mystery i mean there's
no mystery about who the killer is it's
obviously dwayne i mean they don't make
any secret about that um but it does
have enough gloss touches to maybe kind
of endear it to fans of the genre like
the look of it the style of it um the
retro vibe of it i think that's more
in keeping with giallo rather than it
having like a lot of the plot points
around it like i said with the mass
killer and all that kind of stuff so you
know keep that in mind um and also if
you really like or if you'd really like
to see a pretty well done homage to
uh you know kind of the slashers of
yesteryear then you'll probably dig this
as well as i mentioned the tone is a
little bit uneven um you know some of
the characters seem like they're sort of
aware that they're in a comedy and the
other ones are like playing it straight
so it's a little bit odd um there are a
few parts of it that you know that don't
really work or there's a couple things
in there that i kind of wish had been
explored more but they weren't because
the movie isn't really that long it's
only like 85 minutes but i mean those
are pretty minor minor quibbles i
thought this was like a pretty enjoyable
movie overall like it has a really cool
look to it um you know so i thought it
was pretty nifty also um i have to give
a big shout out to
the score and like all the music that
was used there's some casey and the
sunshine band in there there's a boy
from new york city that song i can't
remember who does it and like i said
flight 76 so there's like a lot of
really cool like disco music in it that
you will recognize so i really like that
as well i heard i don't know if this
ever happened or not but i heard that
the writer director was going to
put out a soundtrack album like on vinyl
for this movie which would actually like
be pretty rad because like i said
there's a lot of really good disco tunes
in this so yeah if you like disco if you
like 70s era slashers if you like giallo
films and want to see something that's a
little bit like a giallo film but not
exactly then this would be a really
really good one to check out and like i
said it's available for free on to be at
the moment so that will do it for this
flickers of fear again continuing on
with giallo july and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye